Welcome back to the show!
We once again join SCP-682 and its
trusty macaw sidekick Jerry deep in
the depths of the liminal abyss known
as The Backrooms. The hard-to-destroy
reptile had been seemingly contained
within The Backrooms for such a lengthy
period of time that it was likely even the SCP
Foundation had given up on searching for it.
After unintentionally no-clipping out
of reality, 682 was apparently doomed to
wander these endless labyrinthine realities
until the end of its miserable existence.
The latest level that it had arrived in
appeared to take the form of vast desert
stretching from horizon to horizon. Sandstorms
buffeted the creature, and powerful gusts of
wind forced Jerry to take refuge: clinging
tightly to its much larger friend’s back.
This was level 16, but there was far
more to it than first met the eye.
As the lizard and bird made their
way across the titanic dunes,
strange lights began to circle in the
air above. These were entities known as
Light Guides - singularities of pale light
that bore a strong resemblance to “will o'
the wisp” - ghostly fire elementals out of
folklore. Much like the mysterious wisps of
legend, Light Guides appear to travelers in The
Backrooms whenever there is an impending danger.
You’d think with all the malicious
entities and bizarre hazards that
SCP-682 had encountered in the previous levels,
it would have seen a lot more of these - but
considering how dangerous 682 itself was,
the Light Guides probably had their nonexistent
hands full keeping other travelers away from it.
Either way, their numbers and proximity meant
that whatever was about to happen was going to
be something perilous. Jerry squawked
and nibbled at SCP-682 with his beak,
trying to warn the reptile of the
danger. 682 had no idea what to
expect but made sure to have its guard
up and keep its avian companion close.
The creature’s instincts were sharp as
ever, and the second that the level began
to rearrange itself, 682 was already taking
evasive action. The sand hardened and turned
to stone as great pyroclastic flows began
to erupt from what were once the dunes.
SCP-682 leaped across a deep fissure just as it
opened up beneath the lizard’s feet - narrowly
avoiding a several hundred foot drop into
a lake of lava. Ash rained from the sky
as all traces of the desert were completely
overwritten into this new volcanic landscape.
This was the defining supernatural feature
of Level 16 - an environment that randomly
reshaped itself into different geographical
climates and terrains. Now that it had seen
the level change completely once, SCP-682
was already over the concept. Rather than
stick around and take a bath in the lava,
SCP-682 decided to follow the Light Guides
towards what appeared to be a portal
made out of concentrated blue light.
It passed through the portal
and found itself in a cramped
hallway resembling those aboard a nautical vessel.
Out with Level 16 and in with Level 17
- otherwise known as the naval aircraft
carrier. Though there was no actual deck of the
proverbial carrier, nor any potential aircrafts
in The Backrooms for it to transport. There
didn’t seem to be much happening on Level 17,
at least in comparison to the drastic
terrain shifting of Level 16. There
were also absolutely no entities to
be seen, as far as 682 could tell.
Of course, Level 17 was vexing to the reptile in a
different way: the corridor it found itself in was
such an extremely tight fit, and moving freely
was next to impossible. The Backrooms was once
again telegraphing the fact that it was made
with humans and not overgrown lizards in mind.
Waste of effort. 682 thought
to itself. Not even the most
disgusting human has enough
dumb luck to make it this far.
After a few minutes of struggle, 682 shrunk
down to a more manageable size so it could
traverse the hallways. It was now roughly the
size of a male hyacinth macaw - that is to say:
Jerry-sized - and it crawled through the
narrow corridors of Level 17 with room
to spare. There was still no sign of hostile
entities, and given the propensity for Clumps
to come avalanching out of the woodwork
on previous levels, SCP-682 saw this as
a mercy. It was also grateful to no longer
be exposed to the elements on Level 16.
SCP-682 passed the time exploring the seemingly
empty corridors by having one-sided small talk
with Jerry. The macaw couldn’t do much more than
chirp and squawk back, and before too long 682
realized that it had very little to talk about.
Its main interests were slaughtering living things
and breaching containment, and both of these
topics were irreverent to the current mood. A
wave of embarrassment washed over the creature, as
for the first time it had genuine concern that a
social interaction could go poorly. It didn’t want
to frighten Jerry away, or come across as awkward.
It was just that conversation with like-minded
anomalies had been far easier at the Foundation,
since the shared experience of being contained
was always a good starting point. The reptile
also had fond memories of the time it got to chat
with SCP-079 - an old A.I. that the foundation
secured around the same time as itself.
Though it was an unusual feeling for a
creature so filled with contempt and hatred,
SCP-682 had started to realize that it wanted to
build the same kind of rapport with Jerry. Maybe
getting lost in The Backrooms was exactly the
kind of life experience it needed to become more
approachable to the few beings it could respect.
That being said, the current level it was on was
rather underwhelming as a way of making memories.
Just then, SCP-682 saw what appeared to be
an ordinary human up ahead. It had its back
turned to the reptile and Jerry, and seemed to
be unaware of their presence. A sitting duck.
Oh, good. A distraction. Thought the flustered
lizard. I was totally sounding like I had no life.
SCP-682 charged towards the human as fast as its
shrunken body could carry it. Jerry followed suit,
flapping his wings and flying alongside
682. As the duo approached, the human began
to turn around. What 682 anticipated was a
look of abject horror on the human’s face,
but instead the entity simply stared through
682 as if the reptile wasn’t even there. 682
was confused, but even stranger was the fact
that its consciousness was starting to fade.
682 blinked and in what felt like a second
later, it awoke at full-size, half-wedged in
an aircraft carrier doorway. Jerry was squawking
up a storm, and that was presumably what had woken
682 back up. It also seemed that making eye
contact with that humanoid entity had somehow
caused 682 to faint temporarily. The entity
itself was long gone: much to 682’s chagrin.
This phenomenon was easy enough for any
expert in Backrooms lore to explain,
as Level 17 was home to unique entities known
as Imprints - which resembled humans but had the
supernatural ability to induce brain death
in anything that looked them in the eyes.
Even so, this was an unacceptable outcome to
SCP-682. Had the entities been growing stronger
at the level number went higher or was the reptile
simply losing its mental fortitude? Maybe all the
strange properties of this place were compounding
on the creature and slowly making it go soft.
682 shrunk down again and shook off
the shame of its encounter with the
imprint. The only way to prove that it was
better than The Backrooms was by advancing
through all the levels and taking down
whatever entities stood in its way. This
would probably mean facing at least one more
pompous jerk with a spear - like Tiny and
Argos before - and 682 relished the chance
to triumph in another bout of single combat.
Besides, if another fair fight like those ones
were to take place, 682 would be able to show off
how strong it was to Jerry. That alone was reason
enough to find the entrance to the next level.
The time for brooding was over: it was
now time for action and adventure. Even
if it took one hundred years, 682 would not
rest until it made it through every level
of The Backrooms and left the entire hellish
dimension devoid of the life it so despised.
It wandered the hallways of Level 17 until it
found a door that was discolored compared to the
other ones, almost as if there was a photonegative
spotlight shining on it from the other side. It
was about to pass through when the same imprint it
had encountered earlier stepped into the hallway.
“Fool me once…” SCP-682 growled, and confidently
initiated a staring contest with the creature.
That feeling of losing consciousness was felt
immediately, but this time 682 suppressed it
through sheer will. With all of its vast
brainpower, it fought to stay awake and
even began to concentrate the distressing emotions
into its gaze. The imprint stood and continued to
look at 682, but within mere moments the entity
was frothing at the mouth and falling backwards
against the wall - as if the effects of its own
stare were reflected back at it through a mirror.
682 may have been caught off guard the first time,
but its signature adaptation abilities
meant that there was never a second time.
Exit stage right.
The reptile opened the door to the next level and
moved on to Level 18 - which was
known as the level of memories.
Level 18 was said to take on a subjective
appearance that was different to every
individual wanderer but would usually resemble
a place from childhood. This was no different
for SCP-682 - and the hard-to-destroy reptile was
shocked to find itself in the very same primeval
forest where it and its countless siblings
first went to war against ancient humankind.
There were even corpses littered around
like in the futuristic hallways of level 15,
only these dead creatures were far more familiar
to the reptile. The vast majority were human
warriors in bronze-age armor, still gripping
antiquated weapons such as swords and axes.
Among these fallen humans were the occasional dead
giant beasts - though these bodies were rather
few in number as casualties on the SCP-682’s
side of this war had been almost nonexistent.
682 had never thought it would see this
place or those of its kind that were too
weak to survive the battlefield again.
It was a strange, uncomfortable feeling,
not helped by the raspy whispering voices
that seemed to linger in the wind of Level 18.
Your father will never look for you,
for he has already transcended that momentary
flash of anger that brought you and the rest
of your litter into being. He only has
further use for your mother, his bride.
She is worth a million of you, no matter how many
battles you’ve fought in the name of his hate.
Despite the ghoulish intensity of the whispering
voices, the words they said were clear and direct,
impossible to mistake. But the part that
really caused SCP-682’s blood to boil was
the fact that these voices seemed to know more
about its past than even The Foundation did.
Tell me, disgraced Prince
of Wrath, what hurts more:
the fact that you proved weak enough to
fall into the clutches of your greatest
enemies or the fact that those same lab coats
and soldiers were the first ones that allowed
you an identity of your own – distinct
from the whims of your pathetic father?
Lost in the wicked siren
song of Level 18’s voices,
682 suddenly noticed that Jerry had flown
off again or perhaps he had never entered
Level 18 with the reptile at all. It called
out for the macaw but there was no answer.
SCP-682 found all of this to be very distressing,
especially since these whispers seemed to
come from some powerful unseen force that knew
exactly what the reptile viewed as its greatest
failures. It was different from the influx of
negative thoughts that level 14 has caused,
since that had been a product of 682 own minds.
What was happening here on level 18 was different.
A separate, malevolent consciousness - perhaps
the creator of The Backrooms itself - was
completely aware of all of 682’s childhood
trauma and was deliberately using it against
the creature. Physical threats were one thing
that SCP-682 had always been able to overcome,
but a psychological attack of this degree was
beyond the capabilities of even The Foundation.
Still, there had to be a way out of Level
18 or at least a way back to Jerry. Either
would have given 682 a bit of breathing
room from the influence of the whispers.
Fortunately, things weren’t quite as dire
as they seemed as SCP-682 was about to be
reminded that not all entities in
The Backrooms mean to do it harm.
Enter Entity 198 - nicknamed the Plush Dino
by the explorer who first discovered it.
While Level 18 is not the only level
of The Backrooms it can appear on,
The Plush Dino often patrols the reality of
childhood memories in search of wanderers
in distress. And in the compromised
psychological state it was in right now,
SCP-682 surprisingly fit that description -
thus prompting Entity 198 to come to its aid.
At first, SCP-682 didn’t know what to make of this
peculiar synthetic-looking entity. It approached
with no ill will and wordlessly attempted to
comfort the reptile through gentle contact.
SCP-682 swiped at the creature with its claw.
As always, it was in no mood for cuddling with
a stuffed toy. Entity 198 seemed able
to dodge the reptile’s attacks easily,
and continued to do so as SCP-682 made
repeated attempts to destroy it. Nothing
connected, and the Plush Dino circled the
hard-to-destroy reptile without a scratch.
“What do you want from me,
you worthless little creep!?”
682 screamed at the Dino, at which point the
entity turned and started to speed away in a
random direction. SCP-682 gave chase, pursuing
Entity 198 through its own childhood memories
towards what appeared to be the door that had
led it into level 18 to begin with. The Plush
Dino opened the door, got on the floor, and
proceeded to walk the dinosaur… into the door.
Without even considering whether doing
so would send itself back to Level 17,
SCP-682 followed the plush dino and instead found
itself in The Backrooms Level 19 - The Attic.
Turns out that being blinded by anger always
helps one get further in life! That’s a positive
lesson with no unfortunate implications. Jerry
had already arrived in Level 19 prior to 682,
so chasing the Plush Dino was even more of a smart
decision than the reptile could have imagined.
“Jerry!” SCP-682 said, running up
to the macaw and wagging its tail.
Jerry fluttered down from the attic
rafters and landed on 682’s snout.
“Six-eight-two! Ahoy!” He squawked, having
remembered 682’s designation number.
Apparently, he had been paying attention to the
conversations earlier. This means that 682 had
confirmation that it hadn’t totally screwed
up this new friendship yet. On top of that,
it was nice to know that Jerry had no
intention of abandoning the reptile.
This was certainly a warm and touching reunion,
though the continued presence of the
smugly grinning Plush Dino almost
ruined it. 682 snapped its head towards the
offending entity and barked an insult at it,
hoping that it would get the message and leave.
But Entity 198 did no such thing, preferring
to silently watch the wholesome interaction
between 682 and Jerry from a safe distance.
Whatever. SCP-682 thought.
It wasn’t going to waste any more
time on the impish little stuffed
animal. That’s when Jerry swooped down
and landed next to the Plush Dino.
“One-Nine-Eight.” Jerry squawked.
He then waddled across the wooden attic
floorboards in between 682 and 198 and
squawked again. It was as if he was trying to
introduce the two, and this mortified 682. Was
this thing a friend of Jerry’s? And if so, did
that mean he was going to have to coexist with it?
At the very least, the Plush Dino didn’t
seem to be alive in the conventional sense,
but whether that meant it was an animated
object or some kind of machine remained as
vague and mysterious as most things in The
Backrooms. Even though it didn’t technically
fall into the very broad category of “living
organism” that SCP-682 wanted to wipe out,
that didn’t automatically disqualify the
miniature monster as being disgusting.
Especially if the dinosaur was getting overly
friendly with Jerry. The blue hyacinth macaw
belonged to 682 and it didn’t feel like sharing
- especially not with some clingy toy. After the
awkward introductions were over, 682 and its two
tagalong companions had a look around at Level 19.
It definitely resembled the attic of a
household, complete with dusty discarded
furniture and several boxes of photo albums
and other mementos. There was also the orange
glow - an unusual fiery light that emanated from
beneath the floorboards. SCP-682 didn’t know why,
but the glow reminded it of the same
memories that it had just had to
relive on the previous level. This time
though, 682 was drawn to thinking about
the more positive aspects of its proverbial
childhood: if one could call crushing human
skulls beneath its claws and facing down
entire armies of humans to be positives.
The truth was that SCP-682 was being
mildly affected by the orange glow of
Level 19 - which had the memetic ability to
insinuate its way into the formative memories
of anyone who wandered through the level. But
682 had spent enough time having its childhood
ruined today, and decided to search for the exit.
After all, if there were no entities present on
this floor, it would be a waste of time to stick
around and play into the hands of whatever
was making that orange glow. Thankfully,
it seemed that entity 198 was already one
step ahead of SCP-682 in the hunt for an exit.
The Plush Dino had located a severely damaged
wooden door with the number “20” painted in
orange on its surface. No doubt this was
the entrance to the next level. SCP-682
was still very annoyed that the Plush
Dino had insisted on hanging around,
but if it was going to actually be useful, the
reptile would be sure to make the most of it.
682, Jerry, and the Dino entered the
broken doorway, and found themselves
inside of a wide open warehouse room.
There were several corridors leading
out of the room that appeared to be filled
with crates on wooden and plastic pallets.
This was Level 20 - The Warehouse. Although it
resembled many earlier floors of the Backrooms,
it was surprisingly finite. Both the corridors and
the room were not of an unusual size compared to
their equivalents in the real world, and according
to explorers, the warehouse itself was only about
300 kilometers wide at the most. Those stats
weren’t especially impressive if you asked 682.
Whatever happened to the infinite labyrinths
of liminal spaces? SCP-682 wondered. Ever
since the city level it’s been nothing
but confined spaces, weird mindscrew ones,
and that landscape that kept changing for no
reason. What happened to the classic Backrooms?
SCP-682 quickly came to its senses
and realized what it was thinking.
“Classic Backrooms?”
It sounded like one of those snobby
Foundation researchers deciding what
was a genuine SCP and what wasn’t based on
some incredibly arbitrary standard. Besides,
there were no levels of the Backrooms that
were remotely acceptable for 682 - other than
maybe level 9 - and breaking them down into
further categories went against the reptile's
ultimate goal of destroying this horrendous
place and everything associated with it.
It wouldn’t become like the Foundation
it hated by being specific and thorough.
Broad sweeping statements were more SCP-682
style and when it came to The Backrooms:
every level was equally disgusting.
682 turned to its companions and growled
with what seemed to be excitement.
“Jerry, let’s get moving. You
too, piece-of-garbage dinosaur.”
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained in
the Backrooms?” and “SCP-682 Slaughters Through
the Backrooms” for more of our favorite
reptilian menace taking on the Backrooms!